o no
no sabe pronto seis manzanas duras en la
que de camino abajo no sabía abre ya
está hay que reducir 500 manzanas
gervasio mamani es un agricultor de la
comunidad de capi situada a los pies de
la montaña antes cultivaba papas pero
ahora está orgulloso de sus manzanas la
variación es el resultado del aumento de
temperaturas que afecta al imán y cuyas
aguas escasean
el agua fría y no había ni puede mandar
agua todos cambiamos tranquilidad hoy en
día como ya al calentamiento
el imán se va quedando entonces está el
agua va bajando poco a poco y las
comunidades de abiyán tiene mucha agua
tampoco ya
las comunidades situadas a las faldas de
la montaña claman contra el cambio
climático pero no pueden hacer mucho
salvo adaptarse la experta en recursos
hídricos paola pacheco ha estudiado el
impacto del deshielo del imán y sus
efectos en capillas y bolivia más bien
es uno de los países que sufre de los
impactos del cambio climático en este
caso nuestros glaciares de todos los
andes
las poblaciones como capi y otras
poblaciones que dependen del agua de los
deshielos lo que pueden hacer lo que lo
único que les queda hacer es adaptarse
una adaptación difícil para esos pueblos
frente a una naturaleza que ya no
reconocen y de momento sin ninguna
propuesta política